[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined by Jade warshaw we are
taking your calls on money and life and
relationships whatever you got going on
we're here to help triple eight eight
two five five two two five it's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jay it's been a long time since we've
been together on the show man how are
you I know I've been on vacation John
how's it been great great I had to
remember what my job is here
[Laughter]
I was like what do I do oh yeah it was
good times it's good times we went to uh
Fort Lauderdale Beach got a lot of time
in the sun you know what I'm talking
about came home it was the Fourth of
July and and might I add can I say
something controversial before we get to
the phone line Bring It On we didn't
bring the kids was it incredible yes do
not bring your kids on vacation it's not
a vacation when you bring your kids it's
a trip that's what I heard I heard it's
a trip
you gotta just every once in a while
just do a little something with your
significant other you know what I'm
saying was it magic I'm trying to I'm
trying to imagine being in that space
okay well let me let me just break it
down because I know I I made a couple of
posts from the road and
I was telling them how like when we
first got to the resort man it was so
expensive I got like two waters and like
these little bottles of champagne and he
was like that'll be 68 I was like stop
it stop it right now I can't so you know
I had to take the yeah I had to take I
had to take the waters off and get go
with the Dasani go with Dasani yeah man
but overall great trip great trip great
trip great trip I went camping with with
my kids yeah oh really I should have
known John you're an outdoorsy kind of
guy
I'm just gonna leave it at that I'm
gonna go with your wisdom you're not
don't take the kids oh I like that
because that's right I did not take that
I I took the I took the let's go to
let's go to will in Denver hey Will
what's up brother
uh nothing how are you guys doing we're
partying man what's up how can we help
um so my wife and I are that we've never
gone through Financial Peace University
kind of inadvertently we are going
through the steps
um the only debt we have is our mortgage
um a lot of our peers and our family
friends are having debt problems
um and I think it's causing some stress
and some marriages
I don't think that locally in person we
really have any Financial Peace
University classes available how does
one I I would like to offer that to our
community how does one go about
facilitating that wow well number one I
I just love your heart behind this I
love that you're you know looking at
your community
um you know if you if you're rich but
nobody around you is Rich what does it
matter you know you want everybody to be
able to partake in what you've learned
and what you know works so I really
really love that
um yeah I would just suggest going to
ramsaysolutions.com peace and signing up
to be a coordinator and look we are
always looking for more coordinators
because that work that you are going to
do in that work that so many
coordinators have done I mean that's
what's changing lives right I mean you
got a hold of that information even
though you said you didn't like actually
take the FPU class it's the same
information
I think my wife read the book like a
decade ago and we have not been as you
guys say gazelle intense yeah but we got
there um good and
I I think her and I should probably sign
up and take an official class first
um but from there uh I mean you could
but you don't necessarily have to here's
what here's what I would do at will is
you know you don't you may not need the
money information or the insurance
information but there's something about
working in the messy lives of other
people and you'll hear stories I think
um and Jada is something you and I
experience a lot where in our in our
world where somebody has an experience a
personal experience and they try to pass
that off as expertise and so will you
and your wife have the way it's happened
for y'all the benefit of a class may not
be learning the baby steps you may
already picked all that stuff up the
benefit of the class may be watching 15
or 20 different couples as they have had
to navigate this in different ways and
that when you watch a collective group
of people go through on the same path
that's the road to wisdom when you can
start coming up with these Universal
answers right that aren't just just how
will and his wife did it but it's it's
how we've seen a bunch of couples do it
and that's that's the sign of that's a
really great coordinator that can do
that for folks and so just go to uh
ramsay.com and look for the coordinator
role and that's something we could maybe
facilitate through a local church here
and offer it to the community that's
right yeah you can when you go onto the
coordinator site you can choose what
type of class you want to do so you can
do an in-person class you can do an
online class or you can do like a flex
type class and the flex basically just
means hey you guys watch the video on
your own and then we get together to
talk about it whether it's in person or
online
um it sounds like you want to go like
old school we sit in the room together
we watch the video together we learn
together and I I just I love that
um I think that both ways can be
effective but I gotta say I think that
when everybody's in a room together the
energy is there I just I think that's
Next Level right there so well let me
catch you this it's it's
ramseysolutions.com
FPU
ramseysolutions.com FPU is the is the
site and by the way you can also
you can do it in a coffee shop you can
do it after hours at your workplace
people are starting to pick up these
classes all over the country and
historically they've been done in Sunday
School classes and as more and more
churches have stopped doing Sunday
School classes or they've rolled classes
online
um or they have gone to streaming
services
these classes are popping up in in
different organic spaces and it's pretty
rad to see a group of people get
together after after hours at the gym
and do this class or folks do it after
work together so there's any number of
places where you can do that but I'm
really grateful man oh and absolutely
let me tell you one other thing so much
let me tell you one other idea
um back when when Sam and I first
started hosting classes if kind of like
what you're saying with your neighbors
and the folks in your community we
actually would just like hand tap people
on the shoulder and say hey I'm hosting
this class I'd love if you were in it
and that way we kind of just we picked
10 10 folks had them over to the house
you know I'd make nachos or make a
lasagna or whatever and it was just such
a cool cool experience so yeah man I'm
excited for you that's great so there's
one couple on my heart in particular
that are good friends of us and and
they've shared with us their financial
struggles before but I I've just never
felt like I can
I I didn't feel like they were asking
for advice if like when my wife tells me
she has a problem she's not looking for
me to solve it she's looking for me to
listen and I feel like she was these
folks were looking for us to listen but
well that'd be a great place I I love
that man I think too many men especially
running and try to start solving things
with their advice but there's something
else about an invitation yes if I can
make it available to them and invite
them that's that's right you can invite
them and it's it's you're not shoving it
down their throat but it's hey here's an
opportunity we're gonna be there love
for you to join us stay on the line I'm
going to send you a gift card for a free
year of Financial Peace University that
you can give to that family
and tell them it's a gift on uh from you
to them and uh invite him to the class
and they can come participate and be a
part of it thank you so much for your
heart brother triple eight eight two
five
two two five we're talking relationships
mental health money work whatever you
got we're here for you we'll be right
back
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
we are back this is the Ramsey Show I'm
John deloney joined by Jade warshaw
we're taking your calls Triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so Jade uh student loan repayments
are all the Talk of the Town
I want to say this first I I we were
talking about this a little bit earlier
I was surprised at the number of people
that
I don't know how to say it in a nice way
they came after me and said well I hope
you're happy oh I said what do you mean
you hope I'm I'm happy and it was this
very strong well we know what y'all
stand for and you got what you wanted
and Ramsay's so excited so I guess I
guess just between me and you and the
people listening I'm a fan of
people who were taken advantage of
having their loans forgiven I I don't
have a problem with that I can't stomach
it while they're also making loans the
next semester and so if you're going to
fix the whole system I'm all in I was a
part of that system I get it if you're
gonna piecemeal it as as political
theater and then the very next and then
the summer Session One or summer session
two people would they could have gotten
their loans for given July 1. and turned
around and taken out new loans for a
summer session two and that's what would
have happened exactly so it's not true
none of this is is is is is people being
honest about solving a problem it's
about it's about political theater
garnering all around around the campfire
here absolutely
but there is going to be some big
repercussions of this and so this this
article comes out let's talk about that
yeah it says the Supreme Court struck
down President Biden's student loan
forgiveness plan on Friday which I'm
sure you all know which adds just
another layer of uncertainty to those
who are straddled with payments
um and I'm just going to read this real
quick for more than three years federal
student loan borrowers have not had to
make monthly payments we know that and
by the way that cost taxpayers five
billion dollars per month all right
you're not gonna I'll never mention that
without mentioning that stat of how
freaking expensive just the just the
pause was forget getting to the actual
forgiveness okay but the pandemic era
pause is coming to an end this fall we
know that setting up a financial shock
for millions of Americans in the big
name is stores where they shop so here's
an interesting twist here so we're
seeing that as these student loans come
back John everybody's looking at their
budget going yay yeah yeah like I gotta
find this money somewhere because again
what we know is for the past three years
you know people had this pause and they
had this extra money in their account
and we know that they've replaced that
the student loan debt with other types
of debt whether it's car loans home
mortgages just living life you know what
I'm saying and so now coming you know
payments which are going to resume
August 30th those payments are
substantial for a lot of people and now
we're finding that retail stores are
gonna kind of take the hit because these
folks ain't paying the money it says the
average monthly bill hovers between 200
and 300 per person although it's even
higher for some borrowers collectively
borrowers will resume paying about 10
billion dollars a month and the
resumption of these payments will likely
Force households to cut back on spending
and other areas particularly retail
and I I think that's right yeah I do too
if you're a retailer and people have
been buying your goods and services on
credit the last three years yeah there's
a reckoning coming
um and again what I hope everyone
listening to this so I I do have a heart
I'm a retailer I have stuff I want to
sell right I've got a book coming out in
October and I just keep looking at this
going are you kidding me right but
um
I'm hoping that the consumer is the one
looking at this and saying I've got a
three-month ramp here where I can begin
to make some hard choices have hard
conversations with my spouse with my
kids start getting an extra job what
sell this car because there's gonna be a
bunch of cars on the market in September
and October November that's right
there's gonna be homes on the market so
um I
we we rarely get 90 days or 120 day Head
Start in life that's right when you've
got that right now you know what's
coming if you wait until October just to
go oh my God then that's on you I
created right there's so much time here
um and I you know this is kind of a
funny article you know it says a number
of brands people like um American Eagle
Carters Crocs I think that's funny Nike
Gap these folks are going to be the ones
feeling the hit Victoria's Secret
um and if they feel a hit I think
they'll be all right I would rather
people pull back on their spending find
that margin so they can make their
payments because let's not forget and
you know guys I'm always going to give
you the facts so you can keep it in
front of you don't forget before the
pause half of half of all borrowers were
in default which means they weren't able
to make their payment so that should
tell us as a whole where we were back in
2019 before stuff got ratchet and now
that it is even more ratchet don't
expect dude I'm saying like don't expect
that things are just going to magically
be all right when we knew before that
they weren't all right you've got to
actually make steps to make things
better and like like this said you know
300 in your budget a lot of folks you're
scrambling around right now and I have a
heart for you because I get it and
you're like where's this money gonna
come from it might be your car loan it
might be that hard step of like man I
got this car it's too much car trading
it in and getting something less
expensive because you can only side
hustle for so long like most of us this
payment it's going to follow us around
for a couple of years and how long do
you really want an instacart you know
what I'm saying exactly or or it may be
time to sit down again you got 90 days
it may be time to sit down and say is
this the work I want to be doing is this
the right Community for us we moved here
in 2020 we tried to make a go of it it's
not for us let's is it time to go back
home is it time to find another new
community both you and I have moved for
our careers that's life it's part of it
right is it fun no do you is it cutting
ties great no it's the worst but
sometimes we have to do what we got to
do that's right and you want to know
what John I'm gonna say something
because you you started out the
conversation this way and I was talking
to James our producer and he was like
you know sometimes people think that
you're excited that they didn't get
forgiveness or that you're excited that
people won't get forgiveness and I'm
like no that's not it at all I I just
want people I get upset when I see
people's stripped of their power or when
they when they step out of their power
or when they give their power to someone
else that bothers me and I get way more
excited when there's an opportunity for
people to gain their power back and for
them to realize what they're capable of
and so if that ever came off that way
that's not what I want I want you guys
to know that I want you to win I get
what it feels like to be under student
loans look when we had private loans
some of that interest was forgiven and
it was the best thing that ever happened
I was like oh God thank you for giving
us back this 30 000 in interest so I get
it um private loans work a little
differently than Federal loans though
and it didn't come out in y'all's tax
dollars so that's just at the end of the
day I'm thinking about tax dollars I'm
thinking about how this money is spread
around I did not like the language free
money forgiveness because it's not free
like free it cost everybody else it cost
everybody everything so that's that's
where that comes across for me well and
both you and I have been through it
right yeah our houses you've paid off
way more than us but we paid off
we had commas right yeah come on come on
with the commas so again we're two
people that can speak from it we've been
there we know forget it where you can't
breathe and you got to live a certain
way and all of our friends are driving
these things and living this way and
we're not we've we've been there yeah
both of our families have been there
um put off having like I don't know
about y'all we like we took us a long
time to have kids we all these things
happen because of these these student
loans
but there for me there's a moment when
like with my kids when I wasn't clear on
some instructions and I go up and I got
one kid climbing on the ceiling and one
kid hanging out whatever and I finally
just say okay I'm starting over I'm
gonna be real real clear from this point
forward
and the the my belief in college and my
belief and people getting educated post
High School is strong that's that's I
believe in it yeah my belief in my
friends and and family members and
um community members that were
scientists and and professors trying to
make the world a better place I'm I
believe in it and
I can't take any more calls from 24 year
olds who can't breathe okay and 28 year
olds who's like um marriage has fallen
apart and so there has to be some some
way in the middle that we solve this
problem yeah and if somebody comes in
and says hey I've got this plan here's
what it's going to look like and we're
going to start today and solve this big
thing and man I'm all about like going
up to the kids and being like all right
clear the decks that's right but we're
we're not even close we're not even
close they got to stop making them yeah
Barn they've full stop right right now
if you want to solve the problem you've
got to stop creating it you cannot solve
a problem while simultaneously creating
it period yeah we're arguing about
um the type of blood transfusion to give
while the doctor just keeps on okay
right well they just keep on cutting and
cutting and cutting gotta stop the
bleeding first and then we can start
looking at the damage and see what we
can do about it agree oh man triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you haven't canceled us we'll be
right back on the Ramsey Show so
foreign
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
AAA
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show I'm
John deloney Joy joined by Jade warshaw
let's go out to our Salon in Queens New
York what's up barcelon
hey how you doing we're doing great how
about you
I'm doing good doing good um well me and
my wife we got married back in uh 2020
during covid and um preceding that oh we
just have a beautiful beautiful little
daughter to survive three months ago we
paid off all of our wedding that we had
so we currently owe zero dollars to
anyone Excellent Car Loan that we have
yep thank you thank you except for the
car loan that we have uh we do have a
car loan so but besides that we don't
owe any money how much is the car loan
Our Salon the car loan is about
um I think forty five thousand dollars
for a 74 month
um term so okay
yeah you can't start a call saying I
don't owe anybody any money except
that's like saying I only eat super
healthy food except for twinkies and
Burger King and McDonald's yeah yeah I'm
contradicting myself over there how much
do you make yeah you're right uh well I
make a 105 a year with 15 annual bonus
and my wife makes about uh 55 with
another 10 bonus for her so in Queens
it's a little bit above minimum wage
basically
yeah in Queens based out of Queens is a
little bit above the minimum wage so
yeah well here's the thing right so
we're currently ranting right now and
we're paying about two thousand dollars
in one for a one bedroom apartment and
we don't mind moving out to the suburbs
but in Long Island the houses are at
like 600 we currently have about 25
000 saved up okay and we just want to
know what we should do moving forward
like should we just rent rent save up
more or should we just take that money
and just buy yourself a house now I even
thought about buying myself a condo but
then the HOA fees here in Queens are
like a thousand dollars a month and I
don't want to throw money away like that
so what do you recommend that I do okay
this is really good I'm glad that you're
thinking about this I'm glad that you
hey I'm glad you got some money saved
that's great uh you do have the 45 000
in loans so can I just walk you through
um the principles here that we would
follow and then you can decide if you
like it or not basically okay so buying
a home is is super important right
everybody wants a home that's the
American dream it's we know it's a big
part of Building Wealth but on this show
we see time after time when people don't
do it the right way something that was
supposed to end up a blessing turns into
a bird and it turns into a headache it
turns into them having to sell a house
that they really love to keep and so I
want to keep that from happening to you
especially in an expensive place like
New York so what I would say first
things first A1 is let's get all this
debt paid off all right let's get rid of
this forty five thousand dollar car note
um and it's your choice you can either
pay it off pay off the 45 000 as it is
or you can try to downsize your car
um so that it's less debt and then pay
that off that sort of thing do you see
what I'm saying
so getting rid of that car loan because
we don't want to go into Home Ownership
saddled with debt because if anything
happens you know your home is on the
line right you got to be able to make
that payment so let's get clear of the
debt now the way we would suggest
clearing out that debt is this little
three-step process here we would say
have a thousand dollars saved first
that's your emergency that's your like
simple emergency fund right and so
you've got twenty five thousand dollars
saved so what I would suggest is taking
twenty four thousand of that twenty five
thousand and paying down this car get it
half gone and then pay off the rest of
it you know working hard and using you
know your income
how quickly could you do that
um I we could we could do that within
like at least two years okay that's
maybe even less I bet less my concern
yeah my concern about that is you know
when it comes when it comes down to
cards I feel like let's say let's not
pay off the car and then the next day
tomorrow I get into a car accident and
got a bit right yeah and if I get into a
car accident and I lose that on the car
and my insurance premium goes up and
then I also lose out on the money that I
just paid off the car with whereas I
have I have gap insurance and like if
God forbid something does happen to my
car I feel like gap insurance covers the
remaining balance of the car and it pays
off so you're you're you're you're your
plan in life is to have a car payment
for the rest of your life so that if you
ever get in a car accident
you're not out money am I understanding
that correctly because if that's what
you're saying Our Salon I'm about to
make you look silly here on the radio
and I don't want to do it don't make me
look silly now no you arsenaline you
made yourself look silly on this one
come on Arsenal I think that's just you
saying I don't want to come out of
pocket to pay this off because at the
end of the day you have insurance if
something happens they're gonna pay out
yes you might not get the exact value I
mean that's just part of it
um but you're still going to end up in a
better situation you're paid off seven
percent or eight percent against that 45
000 car over 72 months yeah for the
privilege of something that's probably
not gonna happen yeah you're you're
paying for the car three times over so
that you can avoid something that's not
even something you need to avoid
it doesn't make sense you know yeah that
makes sense that makes sense I get I get
where you're coming in from oh so you
recommend just pay off this car yeah
immediately get the debt cleaned up
immediately as quickly as possible take
on extra work to do it then stack up
that savings back up to 25 000. all
right then okay and only then because
you want to go into the home ownership
no debt with three to six months saved
okay and then we need to start talking
about the real cost around home
ownership because a lot of times we just
talk about the down payment and I'm like
no there's more to it than that when you
go to buy a house exactly I always tell
people keep This Acronym in your mind
you want a stacked deck DEC you need to
be ready for a down payment which could
be I don't know about five five to ten
percent for sure I'd say 10 to 20 yeah
yeah I mean that'd be nice but I'm not
mad if he gets it between
you know yeah as a 20 for a six hundred
thousand dollar house that's 120k look
the reason a lot of money we want you to
have a lot because we want you to have
Instant Equity and usually you need to
get somewhere between at least above
five percent because you don't want to
be you know try to get it 10 to 20. then
you want it you might have to do some
earnest money right sometimes they ask
you to put like one to three percent
down to say like yes I'm actually gonna
buy this house and then you've got your
closing costs and let me put on top of
that okay arsenaline I'm all about it
too
I bought my wife and I bought a house
it's incredible we love it we had it
inspected and then we had a couple of
different aspects of it inspected by
another professional
in the three years we've owned it
I've had to replace the roof
an air conditioner
um we had to replace some water system
and then this past weekend we had the
electric guys out because something kept
tripping down in the basement and the
guys told my wife and I quote you're
going to want to sit down before I tell
you what actually is going on
oh wow the cost is staggering awesome
and maintenance right yeah it's just
life happens man life happens and so
um we want you to be ready yes here's
the thing there's been seasons of my
life when I would have thrown up at the
number they gave us I would have vomited
and then I've been trying to figure out
how to get out of this house
in this case because we followed this
plan all the way through it's annoying
pretty frustrating and the argument my
wife and I had was who had to call and
schedule it
not what car did we have to sell does
that make sense
guess what I'm afraid of is I'm afraid
of obviously dad but I'm also afraid of
the way you know like let's say I pay
the car off and I have money saved but
I'm paying rent every month and I feel
like I'm just throwing money away in a
trash can yeah you're not right I get
that I get that but you're not um my
husband and I we rented for 10 years and
me and my wife rented it for Wow five to
ten yeah also and it
look what you're saying is not I get
that you do feel like it but when you
unders understand the intent behind it
if you understand the the end point the
goal in mind uh and keep your eye on
that then it kind of puts the rest of it
into perspective it's like no I'm not
throwing this money away I'm doing
something smart so that later I can't
you know so I can have the thing that I
want and you understand that there's
some link to that and it's not just uh
that decision to rent does not exist in
a bubble you know it's part of a plan
and everything else right so Barcelona
let me ask you a hard question yeah if
buying a house meant leaving New York
would you do it yeah absolutely I've
been telling my my wife let's move to
Texas but she doesn't want to so well
Texas is a long way from New York but
there's a lot of stops in between but
I'm seeing more and more and more people
say hey we want to have the life we want
over some magical geographical location
so if it means going to Texas going to
Kansas going to Nashville we're gonna
move and get the house that we want
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw listen
on the show we've talked to a lot of
herding people and if you're like us you
live in these you live in a community in
a neighborhood where people are hurting
or you hear the news and you're beside
yourself on either side of the aisle
with how your neighbors are spending
their money how your government is
spending your money and you just want to
scream will somebody please teach these
people
the easiest way you can help out your
neighbors to help out folks in your
community that you will never otherwise
talk to
is simply to like or subscribe or leave
a five-star review of the show because
it kicks it up in the algorithms and it
puts the show in front of more people
who are typing at midnight after they
just got a credit card balance that they
can't pay oh God what do I do how do I
pay off debt and it kicks this show up
in front of them and it puts them on A
New Path the number of people who call
us and say I call I was desperate at 2
A.M at 1am and I ran across this show on
YouTube or I was scrolling through
podcasts trying to find some glimmer of
hope in the darkness and the algorithm
kicked this show up to me it's just it's
staggering how many people call and let
us know it's it costs nothing to help
out your neighbor so just like subscribe
tell your friends if you have a
particular episode that means a lot to
you text it over to your friends send it
around but spread the word and let's
help everybody get their head screwed on
straight when it comes to their life
their relationships their money their
way work all of it we all could use a
little more piece all right let's go out
to Charlotte North Carolina and talk to
the great and wonderful Margaret what's
up Margaret
hey how are y'all today we are partying
how about you
I'm great thanks what's up
so um I'm a single mom I have two kids
the oldest is going off to college I
make about 130 Grand a year and I have I
just started a new job so I have the
potential to make a good bit more which
is awesome
um I have about forty thousand dollars
in credit cards at I have a mortgage
it's around 500 Grand or it's around 500
000 my payment is around 3 200 my mom
lives with me but she pays rent and
um I've tried numerous times to do the
baby steps but I feel like something
always comes up there's always some kind
of emergency And Then There goes my
emergency fund and then there goes the
credit card so I wanted to see would
y'all suggest putting more in an
emergency fund like 2000 instead of
fifteen hundred
what do you I wouldn't
um I I am curious what sorts of things
are coming I have several questions but
um okay so with the emergency fund
you're getting the thousand dollars
saved super fast right like 30 days max
right it's not taking you forever in a
day to get it saved right
no it's not okay so when these
emergencies that are popping up what's
what types of things are popping up
um so a lot of times it can be medical
bills or a car issue
um like I had
um I had a tire blow out and then I had
and then I realized it was time to get
all new tires so
um you know I do have a car loan it's
pretty it's a low interest rate and low
Oh I thought you said you only had
credit card debt
I did sorry I was let me back up car
loan as well how much is that
it's um in total I think it's 18 000.
okay so it's just the credit cards the
car payment anything else student loans
anything like that
no okay
um let me hop in real quick and then
Jay's gonna take it I have to have to
say this
you had a tire explode
and then you realize that it was time to
get new tires
yeah if you live with the new way of
thinking that we're trying to teach you
you can't afford new tires
you can only and do you need them
absolutely do you need me to rotate it
again and see if they'll go through
another few months until you get crap
paid off yes and next month can you put
it in the budget so you can just cash
flow it because you make 130 000 yes yes
and one tire at a time it may be one but
see what I'm saying like if you have
this idea that I can't afford it so I
can't have it that's the total Soul
change we're talking about here
otherwise you're going to keep finding
these little Tiki Tech emergencies and
you're never going to get through with
it sorry Jade no John you make an
excellent point because what I was going
to say to you Margaret is with the
emergency fund it forces us to rethink
what an emergency really is now your
tire blows out on the interstate that's
an emergency that's right but do you
have to buy all four tires at once no no
you don't can you buy the one that you
need and can you get a cheapo to get you
through yes you can
um some of the other things that pop up
you've got to decide okay is there a way
that I can cash flow this because we
don't the goal is not to dip into the
thousand dollars all the time you want
to try to find a way that you can cash
flow it that you can come up with some
extra money that you can cut something
out of your budget in order to make
those things happen and my guess is that
maybe you're calling something an
emergency simply because it was
unexpected but yeah if it's truly going
to be an emergency it's got to be
something that's not only expected but
it's got to be absolutely necessary and
it's got to be there's got to be a time
sensitivity on it as well so a medical
bill I would not go into my emergency
fund to pay that I would be like hey
let's work out something but I can't pay
you today do you see what I'm saying and
I'll set up my budget for next month
yeah so let's try to get to the oh go
ahead go ahead so the medical bill
um diabetic so so you know if I get a
three-month
um I have newer insurance it's not as
great as what I had before if I go to
get three month refills then I might be
spending four to five hundred dollars I
see and so we gotta we got to get that
into the budgeting the budget yeah to
where it's not an emergency thing and I
know that like you said your insurance
is switching so maybe you didn't
necessarily see that coming but that's
what we're looking for and the bigger
thing is with this the bigger thing I
want to find is where's the margin in
your budget because ideally with your
debt you're creating your budget every
month and there's a certain amount of
margin hopefully at the end for you to
put towards your debt snowball which is
baby step two
and so hopefully whenever these things
pop up you're able to go well hey maybe
instead of paying extra on this or
paying extra on that I gotta I gotta put
this in the budget now and I've got a
cash flow it like that does that make
sense
yes definitely so let's try to do that
as opposed to going to the emergency
fund cash flow first and and rearrange
the budget first and then and only then
like I said it's got to be unexpected
it's got to be unavoidable it's got to
be all those things before you really
dip into the emergency fund
um and I think that should help you
um aren't you doing the debt snowball
yes okay and it you just keep getting
knocked back so yeah I think that should
be I mean does that sound like that's
going to solve your problem I want to
make sure we're solving it for you yeah
it does I think it just it gets really
discouraging when you know something
comes up and then like I can't put that
payment on the credit card debt because
I feel like something unexpected come up
so it came up so it is something I need
to plan for better that's fair and
listen it takes about 90 days we've
found it takes about three months for
somebody to level out their budget when
they start and so there's an old
counseling term from the great Urban
yellow it's in it's this everything is
data so it is frustrating but you'll
learn something and so I'm just going to
take that information I'm going to apply
it next month and I'm going to make a
better run at it and then you find out
your insurance isn't as great and this
thing that you got for 100 bucks at your
last job now is going to cost you 400 Ah
that's the worst but it's just data now
I got some more information so next
month I'm going to make sure that when I
have to buy this again
um I've got that that information there
let me ask you a quick question you said
you got a kid going to college and you
have one other kid and your mom is that
it
yeah
I have two dogs
I'm going to ask you a naive question
um
could it be time to downsize house and
you got a 500 000 home yeah
is she paying half please tell me yes
no sir I actually have an apartment in
the house it has a mother-in-law Suite
so uh she pays
um
about she pays about a third and then I
pay two thirds now your two-thirds is it
less than 25 of your take-home pay
um hold on let me ask that real quick
map that when you get off the phone with
us because that could be your problem
there for sure you've got a lot of house
for one kid a couple of dogs and your
mother
yes it may be time to begin to make some
some uh home transitions there but just
something to think on just something to
think on
um
and cut up these credit cards yeah cut
them up and the second caller in a row
that's like hey I only have this one
debt except for these other debts yeah
that's true you gotta take full
ownership of your reality money that you
owe to anyone for any reason is debt
that's right that's right hey on thank
the guys in the booth thank you America
we'll be right back on the Ramsay show
John deloney if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way just go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and have
amazing relationships I'm John deloney
joined by my good friend Jade warshaw
and we are talking about money life
everything AAA
825-5225 it's triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
Lexington Kentucky and talk to Angela
what's up Angela
Hi how are you all thank you for taking
my call I'm a bit nervous oh don't be
nervous Jade's good at this I'm not that
good so you're you're all right
you always say that but you're kind of
my favorite don't tell anybody else well
you just told me she wasn't paying
attention what's up just kidding
um so I was calling
um because I wanted to see if there was
some new thing that I don't know that I
haven't tried to try and get my husband
on board and I found out about Dave
Ramsey about sevenish years ago whenever
um shortly after I got into church and
um I told my husband about it he wasn't
very excited and then he jumped on board
for a little bit we paid off a bunch of
it
um and then he kind of fell off the
wagon we ended up getting debt free and
then got back into that
um and like in recent conversations he's
like why don't we just do our own plan
I'm like because this is a perfect plan
like I know this works when you say fall
off the wagon
to the tune like what does that look
like because is that you know a couple
of hundred dollars or is this like a
couple of thousands of dollars or is
this like tens of thousands of dollars
yeah oh I'd kill him
um no
um just like we were talking about
um buying a house and you know he's
listening to people that say you need a
credit score and like no you don't and
um so he ended up getting credit cards
and then we had a personal loan for a
basement remodel and
um I and this is in your is this just in
his name and you're against it or are
you going along with it
um I was against it
um it was in his name
um but I was a part of it too like One
credit card was in my name that he got
on his account
um
I'm gonna let John hit you up on this
because there's more here
yeah
you're married to a child
you're more his mom than you are his
wife right
yes yes and
you don't like fighting either
and
um maybe it's not unsafe but it's
probably not wise and so you just go
along with it
and at some point you have to say I'm
not going to be your mom anymore I want
to be your wife
yeah
and my guess is
everything is getting put onto this plan
and this plan is getting all the blame
this plan gets all the success and what
hasn't happened is there's not been an
identity change in your marriage
and the identity change in the marriage
is
we are people who will never borrow
money again
ever
the house is on fire come hell or high
water we're not borrowing money and a
tool to make that identity a reality is
this plan
but we CA if you make the plan the good
guy and the bad guy all the time it's
easy to be like let's just come up with
our own
because I'm tired of fighting you and
you're married to an impulsive child
who wants what he wants right now I want
a new basement remodel and he sounds
like he watches a ton of Instagram and
every model is not yet because
um
well because we live with his mom to
help her out and
um it was supposed to be a temporary
situation so that we could save up to
buy our own house and so the basement
was my own place my own space my
um
kind of like separation from her you
took out a loan to upgrade your
mother-in-law's house
it wasn't like a it was I mean it was a
couple thousand dollars but like it's
almost paid off wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I I gotta bust in for a second
I gotta bust in for a second
um
can I just tell you until you if if you
have a mistake that you made
which I think that you taking out that
loan was a mistake and I think you do
too but if you keep saying yeah but and
it was just for this and it was because
and you keep like and it was my
husband's fault yeah and you keep saying
why it was okay then it's no longer a
mistake in your mind and you're more
likely to do it again as opposed to just
going we did that that was so dumb and
never again yeah we learned our lesson
do you see what I'm saying but the more
you caveat it with reasons why it was
okay the more likely you are to do it
again and I'm guessing your husband's
not gonna get on board because you're
not on board
well I'm on board it's just no you're
not no girlfriend you are not on board
you borrowed money why are you living in
your in your mother-in-law's basement
um because she's a widow and it was to
help her out and
um
what did she need help with
um finances she doesn't work
um and
he draws disability and things so okay
it may be time for some
let me just say it like this if I found
myself in your situation
and it's not as though you have were
dropped in here this is just a global
you've made some errors your husband's
made some errors you all found yourself
in this place
you are taking care of somebody who's
not working who's drawing
um uh
either Social Security or disability
it's just a big old mess
I would take my husband out for lunch or
for breakfast and again people always
ask me why do I always say that because
if you take somebody out for dinner
after a couple of hours when you get to
nine or ten o'clock there's no more
productive business meetings happening
so I have something powerful about going
for breakfast or going for lunch when
the sun is still shining and you are
able to be clear-headed and for several
hours in a row and I want you and your
husband to
decide
are we just gonna are we we're looking
at mom she's on disability her kids are
living in her basement because she
doesn't have any alternatives is this
the life that we we want to chart
forward for ourselves or do we want to
look at each other and Say Never Again
never again
and that means starting with we're not
ever going to borrow money ever
that means we are going to always check
in with each other and be people of
honor and integrity with one another and
then with everybody else
and that means we are going to follow
this plan and we've got a laid out plan
here and honey I'm on board and I've
been getting mad at you for not being on
board I haven't been on board either
and we're not going to live at my
mother-in-law's house she may at some
point move in with us because we're
going to take care of her that's great
but we're not going to find our dignity
and worth and stand up tall by living in
my mother-in-law's basement it's not how
it's going to work so we're going to
move out we're going to get our own
place and we're going to start building
on our own two feet and you're gonna
have to ask your husband to be a grown
man and not a child anymore all of this
is going to have to start happening stay
on the line we're gonna I'm gonna send
you Financial Peace University for a
year the every dollar app and I'm going
to send you a copy of my book own your
past change your future I want you and
your husband to read that together we'll
be right back
[Music]
oh
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're a new listener and you want to
know what we're even talking about when
we talk about things like the baby steps
and the snowball and all those things go
to ramseysolutions.com and click on the
get started button we're gonna help you
figure out the next best step for you in
your financial Journey based exactly
where you are today A lot of times
people say well that call didn't have
anything to do with me we can tailor
make this thing for you okay
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
and we'll walk you to debt freedom from
there let's go out to Lane in Calgary
Alberta Canada what's up Lane
hey John hey Jade how are you guys we're
good how are you
pretty good pretty good can't complain
excellent man what's up
so basically I just wanted to I guess
say thank you
um for you guys or to you guys uh just
for teaching what you teach
um I guess for some context uh my wife
and I are I'm 23 my wife's 21. uh we
have a 15 month old daughter and uh like
three or four days ago our house got
wiped out by a tornado no shoot man
y'all everybody's okay yeah in Calgary
wait where are you so we actually live
about an hour hour north of Calgary
um near Didsbury that's I don't know if
that means I mean you but uh yeah I
didn't know they had that kind of
weather there is that normal we do now
yeah uh so this was the biggest uh
tornado in Alberta in the last 36 years
wow quite a few Farms taken out we're
rural so
um thankfully there were four people but
uh no one was hurt by the way
um but uh yeah if anyone was in our
house they would have been
no more we'll put it that way wow uh but
like we we have most of our stuff you
know um we don't have a house we're
living with my mom for the time being
and uh we'll transfer into other things
but I just
you know when it happened like we
hightailed it over there
um
and I I guess to put it in a way that
makes sense like I don't I don't care
financially like yeah like we're we're
on we're on baby step four five and six
um we we have an emergency fund and like
I was way more worried to make this call
to talk to you guys than it was about
our house being wiped out wow including
perspective and I just wanted to say
thank you and mean to the world that you
guys uh teach this stuff to my
mother-in-law that actually introduced
me to you guys and man I'm so grateful
because I don't know where we'd be
otherwise dude that means the world that
you that you took the time to call Lane
Circle back and uh appreciate it and I
think it's important for everybody to
know that Jade and I have no Illusions
we know we're just a couple of
Knuckleheads on the radio you did it
you're the one actually working man and
uh I'm sure wow good for you good for
you I'm glad everybody's safe and okay
and I'm glad that you all get to make
the next step position The Next Step
moved from a position of strength not a
position of desperation that's that's
incredible man
well dude I'm really grateful that you
circled back and gave us a shout dude
that that means the world to us you know
John people say all you know people call
in and and they they thank us and
they're happy with the results of the
plan
and you know we said and we weren't
joking around he's the one that did the
the work there and I think sometimes
we've seen it on previous calls I think
sometimes with Financial Peace
University people kind of get it in
their head that it's a magic trick and
then if I just take the class
the class will do its magic work and
I'll be magically where I want to be
financially and that's not how it is at
all you get the information and you get
to choose whether or not you're going to
implement it you get to choose whether
or not you're going to go all in because
I mean when you really stop at like we
know we know it's a plan that works for
people who choose to work it we know
that it's helped millions of people get
out of debt and change their lives and
not just get out of debt but go on to
build wealth and become you know baby
steps Millionaires and things like that
and but those are the people they choose
to show up every week right because it's
nine weeks so they choose to say this is
a priority for me for nine weeks I'm
gonna cut out and carve out this area of
my time I'm going to show up whether
it's in person or online because you get
your choice and they're the heroes in
this story it's not us we get to like
you said be on here and and be goof offs
on the radio and for some reason people
listen to us and it's amazing but
they're the ones who carve out that time
they do the work and they're the ones
that see the turnaround they see that
Improvement and it doesn't take long
most of the people who really dig into
Financial Peace University man they're
seeing like eight thousand dollar
turnarounds lickety-split you know
within the first 30 days and things like
that so this that call was really a
testament to not only it's not about the
plan it's about the plan plus the person
right and plus their involvement in it
and that's when it works
um so if anybody's interested in going
through the same plan that helped my guy
out come on tornado blew down his house
and yet here he is Financial Peace
University you can find that going to
ramseysolutions.com FPU and one more
thing uh and this is for everybody
listening
we have a bad psychology
um where
I'll forever remember right after 9 11
happened and all of the I remember it
was Senate of the house the Congress was
was on the steps of the White House
singing together and it was this moment
yeah and humans have an ability to come
together in Madness and make
clear-headed next right decisions
um
but man we make the stupidest decisions
in times of it's all good it's all good
we just pretend reality doesn't count
yeah and so short memories yes and so I
don't mean this in a caustic way at all
but what happened to Lane will happen to
all of us life will come at us moms will
get sick kids will have issues tornadoes
will hit houses it's not a matter of
um if it's a matter of when and so this
plan
and I see this plan living a life where
you don't owe anybody anything you said
it earlier living a life where I am
fully empowered to be as free as
possible in my health in my
relationships in my finances in where I
work an ability to stand up tall
in a culture that is so disempowering
man chopping you down when it comes
the most annoying thing will be who's
going to call to the air conditioner
person who's I want to call in and say
thank you and I'm nervous about that
that's the hardest part of losing my
house
it will come do you have a group of
people with you that you can weep with
do you have an emergency fund do you
have these things because it's gonna
come and we had thousands and thousands
of years of farmers who knew this don't
don't go through all your grain you're
going to have a couple of years where it
doesn't rain that's a life and in two
short Generations we've just thought
we're smarter than nature and we can
beat it all with our with our smarts and
our technology it doesn't work man it
will come for you you make a great point
because it's true and I don't say this
to be like a fatalist or to be negative
you cannot plan your life based on best
case scenarios like so many times people
call in and I've been guilty of it it's
like you have this idea of something you
can do but if you really stop to break
through break down your plan everything
has to be perfect in order for it to
work and right now not one Domino can
fall in order for a tour work right and
then what happens that one Domino Falls
that you never perceived could fall and
you're like holy crap everything's
caving in on me and I don't and and
that's that's why things like this are
so important I mean
one one call we had the girls got
diabetes right and she's trying to get
her medication how great would it be if
that's never an issue for her again
she's just got the money piled up she's
got the financial piece you know you I
heard you talking about your electricity
electricity problems and it's like to
just be able to up I mean you can just
up and pay that bill but I know there's
plenty of people listening who if
something happened and the electrical
went out on their house they'd be up a
creek because there's no margin there
there's no room for error my AC went out
the other
week it was happening to be one of the
hottest days and my husband was out of
town the hawk you know it was like no
big deal all right nobody likes to pay
for things like but you know what I'm
saying like just to have that piece of
yeah where is that piece it's the piece
but life's coming the tornado's coming
and again it's not a fatalist thing it's
not a ooh or fear mongers no it's just
life we we just do life with people who
are hurting we wouldn't have a job if
everything went right all the time all
right and so
live a life where you're connected with
other people live a life where you enjoy
going to work live a life where you
don't owe anybody anything and like I
said a minute ago in a world that is
telling you you can't survive without us
stand up tall and say yeah I can as for
me at my house yes we can we'll be right
back
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
Ramsay show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from trusted locally owned
businesses like Glass Doctor Precision
garage door service and Mr Handyman
visit neighborly.com today to find home
experts available to serve you all right
today's question comes from Heather in
Virginia she says the cost of living is
really high where I live and I'm
considering moving to somewhere cheaper
the hard part is that I'm currently
living paycheck to paycheck and barely
able to make minimum payments as it is
how would you recommend someone move
when they can't afford it between just
moving costs deposits on a new rental
setting up utilities
Etc It seems impossible to move so I can
better my financial situation when I
can't even afford my current bills
that's a great question
um
so I love that she's thinking okay where
I live is super expensive if I really
want to get out of this I'm going to
have to move and the best way to do that
you know obviously if you found
someplace cheaper that's great but the
only way to do that is to save up and do
it like you've got to save up you're
gonna have to pause your baby steps or
pause whatever it is that you're working
on so that all of your money can go
towards saving up to actually move
um it is expensive to move John
um it's brutal it's brutal especially if
you're gosh if you're moving States let
alone across town you know what I'm
saying so it's it is expensive I would
suggest to her that right now this is
kind of like
you know we talk about stork mode storm
mode this is kind of that thing where if
you know you're moving you've got a move
coming up you've kind of got to stop put
the brakes on everything and say okay
I'm just saving up to move I'm saving up
for my first and last month's rent I'm
saving up for the moving truck I'm
saving up for all of the foreseeable
things that you may need to pay for
um start writing it down because when
you start move when you when you start
the process of moving more and more
things pop up right and so try to
brainstorm as many of those things that
you can think of off the top of your
head as possible check online I'm sure
there's plenty of lists on there of like
checklists things to expect and just
preempt it as much as possible save it
up and then you're ready to go and then
you're on your way to more margin in
your life because you've got cheaper
rent and cheaper cost of living so good
on you
um here's a couple things that I think
uh might help facilitate this the first
thing is as you mentioned it writing it
down be exact I would I would be as
exact as you are on baby step two when
you write your debt smallest to largest
I would know the apartment you're moving
into I would know the cost I'd call
ahead to this community and say how much
does it cost to turn on
um the electricity turn on the phone the
internet have those numbers and save
those dollars as though you're paying
debts off and that way you know exactly
because it feels so overwhelming but if
you know it's 35 it's 75 it's 110 then
it becomes more attainable once you see
it and then
man there are apartment complexes that
will run your first 30 days are free or
what find an apartment complex that'll
work with you just start calling and
calling and calling here's the second
big one
be honest about your stuff
if you have a couch that you got off
Craigslist or from your great grandma
nine years ago don't rent a two thousand
dollar truck to take that couch halfway
across the country come on John just get
a lawn chair and deal with it I would
rather move I I put a couch into storage
when I was just out of college
and over the course of that year that
storage space cost me 550 bucks which 25
years ago you could buy a leather couch
with its own Cowboy for 550 bucks not
with a cowboy though but okay dude this
couch I got it out of storage I was like
this is disgusting I can't put this in a
house I threw it away that's what I'm
doing so dumb so dumb so yeah either
strap it to your back and move it
yourself but do not do not spend money
to move that nasty old couch yes if it's
a Craigslist thing there's Craigslist in
whatever Town you're moving to yeah um
but you and I have both done life with
no furniture with air mattresses with
with uh with with yard furniture inside
yes we've made it work because again I'm
not gonna owe anybody more money I'm not
living like that anymore and I can't
even remember those days to be honest
with you they're a part of the past so
much and so dude I just wouldn't spend
the money to move a bunch of nonsense
across the country if you don't have to
yeah I know that's right and uh yeah
John you nailed it that is so true I had
not thought about that but you're so
right do not spend money to move that
stuff or store that stuff you know try
to sell it where you're at and then you
know take 20 the 25 you get from it and
buy yourself another you know couch or
whatever in the meantime or you know
you'll go without for a while and you'll
be strong so there you go yes you need a
mattress that's what you need all right
let's go to uh that's gonna you know
that's gonna end up on social media like
this you don't even need a real mattress
get you an air mattress I'm a real
mattress kind of guy I need a real
mattress let's go out to Anthony in
Morgantown what's up Anthony
hello thank you for taking my call it's
a pleasure to be here you got it man
thanks for calling what's up
okay so I'm about to go into college at
West Virginia University okay cool
parents are handful to help me out quite
a bit but I'll still owe about 5500 a
year
uh it's a four-year school that I'm
going to
and so I have about 9 000 in a checking
account and 8 500 in stocks
so would you recommend I take out that
loan and pay it back over time
or simply liquidate all my stocks so I
can just come out of school about debt
free
so okay number one your parents are
helping you out you said you've got how
much in stocks 8 500.
yes and then what was the other money
I have 9 000 in checking fresh savings
and I do have a few hundred and Roth IRA
as well okay so I would leave the Roth
IRA alone I would leave your 9k of
savings alone because you need to have
some savings why can't you um it's 5500
a year
why can't you work part-time and pay for
this bud
I guess I could I've never thought of
that yeah man let's go I never thought
of a job welcome to America yeah you got
you know the stocks if
liquidatum you could find well it's so
uh let me make sure I say this the right
way it could be so much worse of what
you owe per year so for it to be 5500 I
think that's a blessing and I think that
that is something that you can earn like
it is split what are you studying
brother
computer engineering I would have a job
working in I.T okay on my commute on my
college campus tomorrow they were
desperate they will hire you in no
seconds flat and what you'll get over
the course of four years is enough money
to pay your tuition and by the way Jade
touched on something we often think in
absolute cost like what is the room and
board what is the cost of my tuition and
we forget that life happens that you
want to go on a date that you got to buy
deodorant that you got to do things in
life
um somebody offers you a cool
opportunity but you have to travel to
get there so having some savings is so
important I personally would look would
take out all that stock and I would drop
it in your savings account just so you
have 17 or 18 Grand that you can have in
your back pocket but
um
dude I would work in I.T and what you're
going to find over the next four years
is hundreds of the best and dumbest
questions ever asked about it I asked
the dumb ones and you're gonna learn
about Computer Engineering and the
questions that your future boss is going
to be asking the questions you'll be
solving for future customers I would
dude I would do that tomorrow man and
that's going to pay for it all the way
through but I I would work all the way
through college if I were you and I can
predict based on some of the statistics
out there that it's going to make you a
better student working 15 20 hours a
week part-time it's you're getting
studies show GPA is higher better time
management uh people just tend to do
better in school when they work
part-time jobs so let that help you out
do not
don't borrow money on this one yeah okay
okay don't take the loan out don't take
the loan out it's going to be almost
impossible for you to take that loan out
and then take that money and just pay
for it it's going to be so much easier
just to say ah it's not that much I'll
just deal with it later and later sneaks
up on you real real fast so yeah man
you're in a great spot and good call out
Jade if you owe 5500 a semester at a
good school like WVU You've Won You've
Won congratulations work your butt off
and get that stuff knocked out as you go
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined by Jane by
I'm Jade by joined joined by Jade
warshaw
we are partying yeah as you would say
I'm gonna run out I'm gonna run out to
Seattle and talk to the great and
wonderful Roseanne what's up Roseanne
hey how are you guys we are rocking on
to the break of dawn and I'm trying to
uh uh speak clearly is what I'm trying
to do but I'm not doing a great job how
are you
so what's up I'm calling in calling in
what your guys thoughts advice is if we
get
you know jumped in an instant into this
digital currency from our government
I mean what's what what are we supposed
to do are we supposed to be bringing
cash home are we what preparation
or do you think it's just something that
would take this is you know this is
something that would take a long time to
roll out and we'll have plenty of
warning can I be can I be super just
honest and direct is that cool
okay
so back in 2000 I think it was 10 or
maybe it was 2011. I was
um
crippled with anxiety
um okay my wife described me as being
married to a taser and my friends at
work
um they loved having me around because I
was good at my job and they couldn't
stand having me around because I was
always saying yeah but what about this
what about this what about this what
about this
and I had a buddy who's uh he's still
one of my closest Best Friends on the
planet and he works for the banking
commission and one day I had kind of
cornered him and this is as we're coming
out of the ashes of the market collapse
and housing implosion and
Roseanne I was I had came guns a blazing
and I know a lot about currency and I
know all about debt modeling and I was
going after him what about this what
about this and then what if this happens
what if this happens what if this
happens
and he finally said something to me
Roseanne that changed my entire life
he said this at one point he looked up
and realized I wasn't asking specific
questions I was trying to make
him make me feel better
and he looked at me and he said John I
don't have a meteorite plan
and I said what does that mean
and he said
dude if the currency crashes and
everything as we know it goes away
if we get hit by a meteorite I'm not
going to have spent time planning for
that because when that happens
everything in the world is different
from that moment forward in his exact
words he's my buddy so he said
by the time you're figuring out what to
do your neighbor would already be trying
to to
um take your pets for food like like we
think like if something happens we're
gonna prep in this way and this way
these big caustic things that we worry
about sometimes
I mean that's that's zombie stuff and so
if we woke up one day and our government
had taken all of our money out of our
accounts and turned it into digital
currency
that world would be so insanely
different from the world we inhabit
right now
that spending a second worrying about it
or trying to prep for it really is in a
great use of your time
um
can I add to that of course go ahead
um you said something earlier when you
first
came on the call you said in an instant
if in an instant you know we moved to a
digital currency and my first thought I
kind of chuckled because I was like hey
these governments don't do anything in
an instant do you see how go go down to
the DMV they don't do anything in an
instant so that side of things I I
wouldn't be worried about but can I have
permission to can I be Reverend Jade for
a second
because yeah there is part of this that
John touched on it you can't add a
single day or a year to your life by
being anxious that's what the Bible says
it says you know tomorrow has troubles
of its own just worry about today right
so just take it day day by day at a time
and things like this I'm going to just
tell you what Jade warshaw does one of
my favorite things that Dave says when
Dave's on air he says ultimately there's
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
and and these in the in the times that
we live in I don't care what time of
period you lived in nothing is going to
give you more peace we can tell you all
the data all the facts we can tell you
read all the articles but at the end of
the day the only person
or entity that's able to give you peace
in this world is Christ Jesus period I
don't care who's listening out there you
can believe what I believe or not but
that's the pathway to peace and I think
sometimes when we just start asking and
overflowing with all these questions
sometimes I just go back and I'm like
man this Earth has existed for thousands
and thousands and thousands of years
with so many crazy conditions if it
wasn't if it wasn't digital currency
it'd be a meteor you know hitting the
Earth and and you know destroying the
world to be the a dinosaur chasing after
you right so you just have to live in
the time that you live in and trust God
he numbers your days not digital
currency
for clarity Roseanne
I I tend to think that we're already
there
uh during covid the government
government agents they deposited money
in my account they just put it in there
they just made it it's zeros and ones I
mean nothing happened they didn't send
me a paper check they just deposited it
my tax return this year uh was just
deposited in my account so my my
paycheck from Dave Ramsey he doesn't
sign a paycheck I just get it to pot so
we are already moving money originally
we're there if you're talking about
cryptocurrency and using blockchain
technology and all that I'm I'm of the
opinion that that is inevitable at some
point and it's not it doesn't have to be
a bad thing no I'm not worried about it
in the least when we get there we'll get
there but like Jade said I don't think
anything happens over and overnight but
I think so so many times John people get
like weird like apocalyptic and weirded
out by this and it's just like just get
in your car and go to work yeah Roseanne
where does your fear come from I mean
what what stories are you hearing that
makes you think that there's just gonna
be a switch that's flipped
okay this um so again we live in
Washington state it is very difficult to
find anyone who has like-minded values
like ours
um we were looking for a signing station
to sign a petition against a law they
just asked you and we went to this
church and it was that church that we
went to last Sunday
and we love the pastor it's
it is all uh biblical by the Bible
and um and what I was listening to his
podcast and that was one of his podcasts
was about uh digital currency in that
you know he said no the roof isn't
blowing off you know it's it's just that
we you know we may have to look at being
Diversified you know maybe you know
adding some silver
um because he talked about the evils of
printing money and how well they're
doing that up there now yeah but also
there's the equal nonsense of we all
just got around us in a circle and said
we're going to declare that rock as
expensive
it has no value you can't eat it you
can't you can't do anything with it you
can't use it for fuel and so anybody
long term who's trying to build wealth
is not going to buy gold and silver it's
nonsense it doesn't make any sense it's
beanie baby stuff okay what I love a
bunch of gold bars I would take them if
you want to give them to me but I'm
going to turn right around and sell them
and convert them that sounds like a
person who is anxious themselves and is
trying to come up with Biblical based
excuses for making dumb decisions I know
that's right okay and so he might have
been a wonderful person and a great
communicator at church and have a loving
group of people but if he's trying to
give you some half big biblical reason
why you need to get off of
um
diversify from the U.S dollar enroll
into cryptocurrency and buy silver bars
on behalf of the church you need that's
I would distance myself from that
nonsense it's just not true it's not
accurate I saw a study uh yesterday that
despite all of the rhetoric and all the
stuff making the news
that the US dollar has actually gained
strength yeah I saw that right from I
think it was 59 from 53 from the the
marginal Revolution guys it's all this
stuff is just in the ethos guys it's you
just gotta continue to plug ahead with
the data we got and when change happens
then we're gonna be ready for change
it's gonna be great yes and it might not
be great well what else what are you
worrying about it you got to live your
life you worry about today tomorrow has
troubles of its own that's exactly right
Roseanne thank you so much for the call
thanks to the guys in the booth and
thank you America we'll be right back on
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where people hang out to
talk about your money your marriage your
relationships your mental health your
work whatever you got going on in your
life we're here to walk alongside you
and help you make the next right step
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm John deloney joined by Jade
warshaw and we're taking your calls on
just about everything aliens on Aliens
yeah we're just talking about aliens
during the break
golly man not aliens guys yeah you call
about aliens I'll talk about them I'm in
I'm in oh um there's some Mass confusion
back there with the the guys with the
booth dude the booth guys especially
Zach the YouTuber
to uh
needs
to get off the internet all right let's
go to Phoenix Azu and talk to Lindsay
what's up Lindsay
you too what's happening
okay so this is not a happy topic but
I'm happy right now okay all right
excellent excellent what's up sorry I'm
just excited
um I we are getting sued all right me
and my husband we are getting sued by
the credit card company okay I can feel
you smiling as you're saying the words
so we're getting sued
yes we are getting sued not a great time
but you know God says joy and you know
the hardness I don't know how but we are
but anyways I am a mess I don't know
where to go from here uh We've made this
hole for ourselves pretty deep I know
Dave Ramsey I've done the book I've done
financial pieces my husband he's not
always on board he did not read the book
but I read the book all right
I am struggling we don't have we're not
on baby step one at all we're not on any
baby steps we're getting sued I talked
to a lawyer key or paying a lawyer I'm
just I'm frazzled I don't know where to
go from here biblically spiritually they
Ramsey Lee okay I want to stop you there
first thing is
I want you to take as deeper breath as
humanly possible as deep as you can I
want you to hold it okay
hold it
for one
two
three exhale let it out now I want you
to take your elbows
and I want you to pull them towards the
floor so your shoulders are super far
away from your ears
okay pull them all the way down
here's my promise
the sun's gonna come up and y'all are
going to be on the other side of this
okay
okay it'll be a mess to get through it
that's all good I've been through messes
Jade's been through messes we all go
through messes you will come out on on
the other side of this cool
okay so how big Oh and before we get
into the into the details
no more talking bad about my friend
Lindsay Fair
yes we're done have you done stupid
stuff
all the time okay that's it me too
me too
the only thing we can do is work on
moving forward but if you carry that
around you know the difference between
guilt and shame the the difference
between guilt and shame is this
guilt you do something dumb you you
borrowed a bunch of money you didn't
have and then all of a sudden the debts
come due and you don't have the money to
pay it and somebody sues you and you're
holding this cinder block
and you're holding it that's guilt that
was dumb your body's telling you it's
dumb your friends tell you it's dumb the
banker tells you it's dumb it was dumb
shame is when you put that sucker in
your backpack and you say I'm dumb
and you're not
okay I want you to say stop yeah I'm
positive I'm positive okay I wouldn't be
doing this if I thought everyone who
made mistakes were mistakes themselves
okay okay I would I would be doing
something else with my life
that's my promise okay so we can dig
into the numbers but I want you to make
sure you're with me full on that this is
not an unsalvageable mess okay and
notice I don't even know what the
numbers are but I'm sitting next to a
woman who paid off almost half a million
dollars of a hole me and my wife paid
off
um six figures
of a humongous hole
so I know us too and it well Jayden and
Sam are brilliant smart me and my wife
aren't stop that okay
so we can do oh actually my wife's
pretty smart I was gonna say don't put
shoes
but all to say is you're good okay we
squared up now let's get into the
numbers part of it so how much are we
looking at for the credit card debt that
you're being sued for
so
um there might be three lawsuits but
right now there's two okay um for sure
two is twelve thousand like 700 and some
change okay and the second one is four
thousand and like 300 and some change
and they're both in different courts
because of the amount but okay so I I we
were able to settle it in the very
beginning when we were able to pay and
we had the money kind of sort of we
could have borrowed from a from a family
member but
um honestly I think Pride got in the way
and we were just like why are why are we
paying them we've been paying them for
years and it hasn't gone down very much
and you get in that hole of like credit
cards you're evil but it's not like we
didn't no right it's not like you didn't
know that they charged with interest so
sure I don't know but sometimes people
don't understand exactly how it's
accumulating
right yeah
um yeah and so we just we actually had
16 different types of debts
um since 2015 and I and my husband have
paid them off one by one great snowball
great
um how much have you paid off Lindsay
um like maybe around in total probably
around 60 000. it's incredible very good
incredible you're at the Finish Line you
got three left
hey well we made mistakes with the three
left the three left is like who cares
I think you're focusing more on the what
you're perceiving as a loss than you are
on all the wins that you've had along
the way
and by the way let's cut to it are you
getting sued as an attorney contacted
you or did you get one of those letters
from somebody saying they're
representing such and such credit card
um uh I'm pretty sure well I got it from
the county the county person came to my
door okay
that was for real I was like you're like
a real one yeah these are the last three
you've got left they're suing you okay
you've paid off sixty thousand dollars
this is great what how much money are
you working with every month that you're
putting into your snowball
um well that's where you that's why I
called because there's nothing we've
been
we've been Reckless we've been acting
like we've been debt-free kind of all
right let's do this this is an important
call Lindsay and there's millions of
Americans going through this I'm going
to hold you over to the break stay on
the line I'm gonna put you on hold stay
on the line and when we come back we're
gonna bring you back because I want to
talk through this all the way through
because you aren't by yourself
unfortunately you're most of us
we're gonna use your case as a way to
help everybody change their life hang on
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
we are back we're going out to Lindsay
in Phoenix so Lindsay was on in the
previous segment before the break and we
held her over so Lindsay is married they
have been paying off debts for years
they paid off sixty thousand bucks
but by her own admission they started
screwing around and they made a bunch of
decisions that were weren't the smartest
ones in the world now they're getting
sued they got served by the county
pursued by the credit card companies by
at least one and probably a couple more
or are on the way
um Lindsay before the break you said you
and your husband have just kind of been
messing around just kind of making dumb
decisions tell me more about that
ah do I have I'm just kidding
um mostly honestly when I do my
budgeting we don't stick to our budget
that's our biggest thing is we don't
stick to the budget and then fun things
happen or people invite us places and we
say sure but then I look at the budget
and I'm like we really shouldn't do that
but then we don't stick to the budget
and we're like that's fine I have a
question I have a question and I might
be being a little hard on you
um no so go ahead I'm used to it I just
I'm like what is more is it gonna take
you're getting sued like what what type
of situation you are I mean clearly you
already had lots of debt so you felt the
weight of that you felt some of the
freedom from getting out beneath under
from beneath that debt
um the minute you kind of let your foot
off the gas you're over here you I think
you said you had three uh debts left and
you're getting sued why I I I'm
struggling to understand
how that's not enough to make you go
wake up call like we need to just finish
this out and we need to I'm trying to
understand why there wasn't a behavior
shift there
I think honestly to be honest I don't
like the shift blame anywhere right just
to myself because I can only control
myself sure but in my marriage
um one person
didn't agree with Dave Ramsey one person
who shall rename remain nameless
he didn't agree with uh you need a
credit score you need a credit card did
you need this and I'm like uh no I was
just like no you you don't you don't
need any of that you just need cash cash
is like literally king that's all you
need so you're attributing this to you
and your husband not being on the same
page basically
yes I think that was the biggest thing
that was the hardest was we weren't on
the same page because he just didn't see
it he didn't read it he didn't
experience it like I he went to
Financial Peace University and he was
with the idea but when it came to
actually doing it he wasn't with it you
know so John is going to talk to you
about that
um let me give you just a quick take
away from this being sued situation
um you're gonna get sued and you may
have to go to court if you can't get
them to settle with you ahead of time my
guess is because I know you've paid off
sixty thousand dollars of debt you
probably have the money to clear the 4
000 one of the debts was four thousand
three hundred dollars you can probably
pay that this month
it's that money is laying around
somewhere I know it is it's in your
budget you guys you you guys need to
look at the budget and get that thing
settled call them up say hey we'll give
you 2 000 we have it in cash settle it
same thing with the one that's for
twelve thousand seven hundred so settle
it for pennies on the dollar dimes on
the dollar and get free of that what how
much is the third debt
um the third tip I don't remember I
think it's around the five or six
thousand dollar Mark they have it sent
us really any letters they defaulted it
I'm pretty sure okay so it's just in
default section agency so we're let's
there's three debts left it's the debt
snowball smallest to largest so we're
gonna do the four thousand three hundred
dollar one because the other one is in
judgment we're gonna go ahead and do
that one and then clear out the five
thousand dollar one okay you guys have
the money in the margin to do this
but
and John's going to talk to you about
this it's not it's not a magic trick
right you guys understand you have to
put in the work so if they make a
judgment against you it's literally just
gonna be a yet another set of people
telling you you have to pay this right
so we don't want it to get that far it's
already gonna you know your credit's
destroyed and that doesn't matter anyway
but you got to pay it yeah so John yeah
I I have I would kick myself if I didn't
ask this and then maybe way out of line
here
um
are you safe
oh yeah you're good yes like you mean
like safe as an emotional like am I
being kept am I in the house like is
that what you're saying I just want to
make sure you're all right
oh no I'm no I'm I'm perfectly fine okay
so I'm more than
here's here's the path forward I don't
want y'all to mention Dave Ramsey
anymore because Dave Ramsey's become
um it's become a third rail excuse
and it's easy for your husband to
dismiss some old guy
who's got glasses who lives in Nashville
it's easy just to dismiss that guy and
it's easy for you to not be honest about
what you need and what you want and the
dreams you have and just pin them all on
this old guy in Nashville Tennessee
and so I want you to stop using Dave
Ramsey as an excuse as a marker as a way
to coerce or manipulate or push your
husband into getting you what you want I
want you to do the hard scary terrifying
thing and be courageous and sit down and
tell your husband I'm so scared I can't
breathe foreign
I'm so scared that I can't live like
this knowing that at any moment
if you say the wrong dumb thing at work
you're fired and we are out of our house
that if I say the wrong thing at work
and I get fired in this current world we
live in we lose both cars because we
have nothing or we're about to get a
judgment against us
for X number of dollars plus lawyer fees
plus whatever emotional damage the
credit card company thinks they've
endured
What's it gonna take husband because
right now you're acting a lot more like
his mom than you are his wife or even it
can I more maybe even a kid because do
you want to know what my son does my son
will say Mom ZZ wants to watch a movie
ZZ wants to know if she can have ice
cream and that's my daughter and so he
pins it on her thinking he has a bet she
has a he has a better chance of getting
it he's being just a good kind brother
asking for a sister but what he really
wants is he he wants to watch TV or a
movie he wants ice cream and I so agree
with what John is saying when you pin
everything on Dave Ramsey wants us to
get on a budget that's right Dave Ramsay
you know and not feeling comfortable
enough within your marriage to say I
want here's what I want to do and here's
what I believe is going to help
you know this is just yeah this is you
know and just being free and open to
share yeah
and sometimes
um people
nag and complain and whine to their
spouse about getting with the plan and
they don't get it with the plan because
either one of two things the person's
not on the like you're not fully on
either you say yes to stuff too or
you've got had a bunch of schemes over
the course of your relationship with
this guy and he's like oh I'm gonna do
this let's do this have you tried this
let's try this and Dave Ramsey is just
yet another scheme and a long line of of
schemes that may not be you guys you
guys have clearly gone after it and done
it and done it and done it and done it
but at some point you have to have the
courage to look at him and say
I'm tired of being scared in my own home
I'm tired of feeling unsafe will you be
a part of building a new marriage where
we are completely unified in this deal
and we are safe together and then you
can have the peripheral discussion after
that which is well I feel safe with a
credit card well I don't feel safe with
a credit card would you feel safe with
six months and cash in the bank so we're
Our Own Credit Card yes I can buy that
cool that's in the plan
but you see how those steps become a
part of how do you fulfill this new
identity it doesn't become the reason
why you do everything we gotta do the
baby steps no man you got to get out of
debt and keep your family safe yeah heal
your marriage the steps just help you
get there yeah you see the difference
yes okay I want you to hang on the line
I'm going to send you a couple of things
I'm gonna send you
um Financial Peace University the
updated one and it's going to be on me
and missing you every dollar the best
budgeting app in the world for a year
the premium one that links to your bank
and I'm gonna send you a copy of own
your pass change your future my book on
figuring out what do I do next okay I
want you all to read that stuff go
through it and change everything
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show hey you
can now watch the Ramsay show live on
Twitter
twitter.com
ramsayshow for you people who are
wondering how can I spend more time on
Twitter we got you what about the people
who
never mind
I I don't I wouldn't I didn't know
Twitter was twitter.com twitter.com
ramsayshow get on it it's a new way you
can consume the show so it's got
YouTube's podcast Radio
Twitter just some random guy on the
corner street corner just yelling it out
as loud as you can
wherever Twitter is different from this
not where I left it let me just put it
like that it's different me and Twitter
never dated so we're gonna be on MySpace
any day now we're hoping to put plug it
on MySpace here soon
um come back Myspace no Tom quit
gardening or whatever you're doing
painting and come back all right let's
go to Pensacola and talk to the one and
only Destiny what's up Destiny
how's it going
oh well how are y'all oh well we're
doing good too what's up how can we help
Okay so
my husband and I uh we have two kids
three and one and
I'm stay-at-home mom he's a teacher and
we bought a house back in 2016 so we've
got a mortgage that has like a three
percent
um interest rate the mortgage is only
like 630 dollars but we have
um a couple loans some uh bad credit
stuff uh One car loan
and it's kind of at this
uh he's trying to do woodworking on the
side and I have a friend who's who does
website buildings who's trying to get me
websites so I can hopefully start a blog
to make some money
um but we're kind of at that uh we
barely make it to the next check because
he only gets paid once a month
and so the option
possibly is to move in with his
grandmother who's 83
um and and that's us moving in with her
and selling our house selling it the
equity we figure
should get us to where we're done as far
as this
we pay off the car pay off the loan that
we took out to fix our roof
um all the old stuff will be taken care
of and it would also leave us enough
cash to pay for my husband to have a
Dependable truck because his is not
Dependable
um
but it's just we're not sure if it's
smart or not because
she's talked about me because her
mortgage is assumable so she talked
about maybe passing it on but
uh he's kind of iffy on that so Jade
you're just not sure Destiny I'm gonna
jump in here Jade he's taught me in any
moment Destiny I I
let Jay dig into the math but I don't I
don't think this is I don't think this
is the path of selling your house
um
because you're still not addressing the
core issue and here's the core issue and
I'm coming from my wife's been a
lifelong teacher I've been a teacher
I've been in education my whole life my
whole career so is my wife that's that's
who we are
and with all due respect y'all have
reached a a place where you can't afford
to either have a stay at home wife with
two kids just on a teacher's salary
or um your husband's gonna have to
either you're gonna have to go get a job
or your husband's gonna have to begin to
look into different work because you
simply have an income problem because
that you're gonna get the roof fixed
you're gonna pay all this debt off and
then the air conditioner is going to
break at some point and you still have a
life with zero margin in it
and I know that sounds caustic but you
all have to think outside the how do we
just breathe right now it's a it's a
feels like a very scarce poverty mindset
I just got to get to tomorrow I'm going
to do whatever decision I can do today
to get me to tomorrow even if it's
cutting off my my leg at the knee just
so I can get to tomorrow well now you
can't run tomorrow you can't walk
tomorrow right right yeah John you're
right on um you said something you said
we're barely making it to the end of the
month because my husband only gets paid
once a month
that's not why it's not because he only
gets paid once a month he could get paid
twice a month or you know whatever it's
just there's not enough money that he's
being paid and that you're being paid
and so John's right it sounds like an
income issue because here's the thing
like you said the mortgage is three
percent is 630 per month you ain't gonna
find that again like that it is
you can't rent that cheap you can't yeah
so getting rid of that is not the issue
matter of fact hold on to that because
it doesn't get any cheaper than that
um I
I 100 percent agree with John
um I'm a mom I had some mini you know
four years where I worked from home uh
in order you know to be at home with my
kids and I loved that
um and did a lot of work to be able to
do that
um
I hate telling moms that they can't stay
at home with their kids I you know
because that's the dream right but you
also have to be able to afford it it's
one of those things there's so many
things that we want in life but at the
end of the day there's a cost to it I
always say the best things in life are
free but the next best things are going
to cost you right and it's true you know
if you you know having the love of your
family and all those warm fuzzy things
that part's free but if you want to be
able to stay at home if you want to be
driving the car if you want to be doing
all those other things that goes along
with it that's the part that's going to
cost you and it's not always you know
it's in dollars but a lot of times it's
also in sacrifice
and so you might be able to get to the
point that you can be a stay-at-home mom
but as it sits here it really does sound
like with the amount of debt you have
and with the amount of money that's
coming in it's not possible because your
husband could probably get another job
but what what kind of quality of life is
that for him to have two jobs you know
in in burning the candle that both in
ends on that and then you've got the job
of staying home as a mom but it's not
bringing in money
so how does that sound Destiny I know
that's hard to hear I hate saying that
it is very hard because that
it hurts a lot because I mean that's and
that's what I I've been trying I've
looked online trying to find anything
remote anything that I could do from
home so I could at least because that's
the other issue is we've talked about me
going to work but Child Care is so yeah
this is here and so and we and we looked
at it it was literally
if I took a if I took like just kind of
like a retail job or something by the
time that we pay child care and
everything comes out we have like two
hundred dollars for me to work how old
are the kids
one and three yeah okay yeah you've got
it for a while what is uh what's what's
a teacher make in Pensacola
uh 47.5 holy dude
just for people who
get elected into office who choose how
to spend my tax dollars for God's sakes
Pay Teachers and police officers and
firemen more okay please just stop this
is insane so here's the the gross part
man
um he's probably gonna have to get
another job
to as a Sprint to pay this debt off yes
but there is work from home I I know she
can find I know you gotta keep plugging
you got to keep plugging along and
fighting because it's out there and it's
a lot of it and
if if it's not that it's you creating
something I don't want you to go well I
tried a couple of things and stop
knocking on doors because that let me
just tell you it is out there and you
will find it you've just got to keep
committing to that I would not I would
not hang on creating a Blog that pays
sure oh yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
I wouldn't hang on to that as the as the
key there is definitely work from home
yes but I don't I don't want you guys
you sitting around applying for a couple
of jobs it's not happening you're
frustrated your husband like I'm a
teacher that's all I am and I get that
mindset that I get it
um but man you make 47.5 and your
family's struggling and I don't want you
all to both go well I guess that's the
next option is to sell this incredible
situation we've got don't move in with
our grandmother who may or may not
Adidas over a house we may or may not be
able to afford
um he may need to have a hard
conversation about
is this the career for me for a while I
need to go sell things I need to get out
there and figure out another way to do
life and you need to keep applying
applying Appliance yeah you'll get
something
it's not fun it's not fun but you're
smart I can tell you're intelligent like
you have so much to offer so keep
applying you will find something this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is Psalms
19 1. the heavens declare the glory of
God the skies proclaim the work of his
hands
Robert Fitzgerald Diggs AKA RZA
says inspiration is found everywhere if
you look hard enough
way to go guys
that's from a calendar in Austin's
bathroom
[Laughter]
inspiration is found everywhere if you
look hard enough
there it is
let's go out to Steve in each tone
what's up Steve how we doing
how are you thanks for taking time
absolutely man what's up
um so God
I've been thinking about so I I have um
I have a good job uh a stable career
um my deaths I have three debts that
total about 480 000
um but they're low interest I've got a a
home that's about 150 that's a three
percent and I have a vacation home
that's like two and one two five percent
then I got a car note that's like 1.75
with 30k
so I'm I'm trying to decide you know
these are and then I invest I
um I save like 250 every week that goes
into a mutual fund I do my retirement
which is about 1500 a week
um that I put into to maximize my
retirement
and I have about you know 200k in
savings
um and then about 250 in mutual funds
and then you know a you know like a a
good retirement account
um so I didn't know if I should continue
investing in mutual funds or should I
pay off these debts one by one even
though they're so low
um so that's kind of what I struggled
you know and I have my Reserve so
what's Reserve mean
um well I have like 200 000 in in
savings accounts I mean you know just
for emergency
um okay awesome Steve yeah you are
awesome great great job
um great job on the retirement great job
on the savings
um
something I noticed that I kind of
thought was funny I just gotta say it it
was interesting to me that when you
talked about your debt you really only
talked about the interest rate or you
highlighted that it was low because the
interest it was in the interest rate oh
it's only one percent three percent but
then when you talked about your
retirement you didn't talk about those
by the interest rate you talked about
them by the actual amount and so that
lets me know that actual amounts do
matter so if it's 200 if retirement's
250 000 then
the rental for 200 000 is also do you
see what I'm saying like the weight
matters on both sides so how much you
owe in your house 150
um so I have my my primary residence I
owe 150. what do you owe on that on the
vacation home
vacation home I owe 300. what do you owe
on your car
Thirty Thirty Thirty so here's a good
thing I don't know if you're gonna do
this or not but what I would suggest I
like a debt-free lifestyle I'm just
saying I like the freedom that it gives
I like the piece that it gives
um you have the the money that if you
wanted to you could probably and
probably the cash flow as well that you
could probably clear out your car and
this rental
in no time if you wanted to if you
wanted to or you could pay off your
mortgage
um you've got the money laying around
that you could do a lot here maybe you
could sell the rental pay off your
mortgage keep some of the savings and
pay off your car like you've got you've
got several options here the question is
what's most important to you
I think I think what's most important is
reserve because you know I'm a I'm a dad
uh I'm 51. I mean I don't have any major
health issues but you know I I just want
to be the guy that in case
something happens I've always got the
reserve tank ready to go so here um Let
me let me I uh like I'm with you I grew
up in Houston I'm a little bit of not a
little bit I'm a lot conservative on the
risk profile okay I want to make sure
I'm squared up and especially when it
comes to my wife and my kids Fair same
team on that one
yeah
I cannot marry but okay but I I mean I I
make sure my kids are you know I put 500
a week a month into their uh retirement
um you know 529 that's right yeah
let me say the greatest gift you can
give your kids at this point
is that Dad is stable
I can't think of we did that study of
ten thousand millionaires
none of them were
foregoing paying off their house and
trying to trying to Gap the market
there's something about having a home
that nobody can ever take away from you
ever
and so come what may you will have a
home those kids can come home to because
it's mine I own it despite how high
Texas keeps jacking up y'all's property
taxes
and so if I'm you uh the best I can give
you here because here's the deal I can't
I can't argue with you on the math if
you've made X percent return against the
the percentage points if you're playing
that game you and I are talking you're
talking Spanish and I'm talking Italian
we're talking different languages the
language I want to talk is a
long-term peace in my home
to where it is a place of warmth and
safety for me to put my head down I call
it my head tax that my sleep tax
um my head and sleep tax
I pay that six percent I have no problem
paying that six percent between having
no debt and having a two and a half
percent interest rate on some vacation
home versus and versus the nine percent
I made in the market or the eight
percent or the twenty percent some
people lost last year right so I'm not I
don't even care about it because I'm
playing a different game the second
thing is bro if I'm you right now before
the day was over I would wire I'd go
down to the bank and I would wire my
mortgage and I would have a paid for
home that nobody can ever take for me
ever again and I would pay my car off so
that no one could ever take it from me
and I'd have twenty thousand dollars in
the bank and I would strongly consider
selling this vacation play home and I
would save up and buy something in cash
how much do you earn every month
um about 58 000 uh that's gross so net
you know minus thirty percent uh in
taxes or 28 so my gross is about 58 a
month yeah fifty eight thousand or fifty
eight hundred
58 000. yeah okay he makes a lot of
money that's what I'm saying you're
doing great man you could probably hang
on to the rental but just say I'm gonna
pay it off pay it off in six months yeah
you've got that's what I'm saying you've
got so many options here and what John
laid out is exactly right and we're
trying to lay it out in a way
um you're not giving up anything that's
what I want you to hear here you're not
giving up your security you're
increasing it by paying off your
mortgage paying off your car committing
to take a couple of months here a year
pay off the rental and you know if as
long as you always have about three to
six months of savings you're good you're
the type of guy who wants more than that
and that's fine but let's just put it in
the right area of priority at the end of
this plan you're gonna have everything
that you have right now it's just going
to be paid off and more secure and let
me let me do it a simple way because
you're a smart guy and we'll just do the
math backwards would you ever take out a
HELOC on your home to invest that money
in the in a mutual fund
um
you're so close
um here's the thing you make a ton of
money
and it may for whatever reason the idea
of risk
keeps you up at night the idea of not
being able to provide has buried itself
in your soul
and for whatever reason it could be
historical stuff it could be childhood
stuff who knows why that's there the
reality is it's there and so Dave has
taught me personally as my life has
shifted and changed since I've worked
here that I'm going to lean on ratios
and that's what's going to get me
through the day I'm not going to owe
anybody anything ever
and then when I get make this much X I'm
going to put 15 of that away when I make
this much X I'm going to buy this rental
home and I make this much X I'm going to
put this in a fund for my kids so they
go to school within five months you
could have both of your kids funded
through most of med school right so it's
just a matter of saying I've I've ticked
it off I've ticked it off I've ticked it
off and we are good to go but man I
would start with I don't owe anybody
anything and let that sit into your soul
for a bit and try sleeping on that one
my promise is you're going to sleep a
little bit deeper and your home's gonna
be a little bit warmer to come home to
hey that's it for today's show Jade
it's always a pleasure guys in the booth
and even Austin thank you all so much
thank you America we'll be right back on
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]